Here's my solution.
The initial state accepts
on the blank symbol.
The empty string is balanced naturally.
While encountering a 0, we move to
state q1, and go hunting for a 1.
On encountering a 1, we move to
state q2, and go hunting for a 0.
As we hunt for a 1,
we skipped past all the zeros and x's.
And if we do find a 1, then we move on
to state q4, which will rewind for us.
And we do the analogous thing for q2.
On the other hand, if we encounter
a blank instead of a 1, then we reject.
There were no 1's to match.
Or in this case,
if we're looking for a 0 and
encounter a blank instead,
that means that there's no 0 to match.
Assuming we do find a match, we end
up in state Q4 which then rewinds.
It moves left past all the Xs, the
zeros, and the ones until it finds that
blank symbol, which we crossed out
initially in this transition here.
It exes that out and
then moves to the right, so
that we're ready to
process the next symbol.